going my name and welcome to our press
winger it's a game that was kind of kind
of lost somewhere in the internet and
found by a couple bras suggesting it to
me
it's basically an opera game we're gonna
start on adapt pretty sure I'm a male
you may think that I'm sitting on the
floor I don't know why but you are
absolutely correct
all right Beach arrivals to the
spotlight sing your heart out baby I'm a
pretty pretty solid singer in my mom
would always say that I sound like a
bird not that healthy audience wait
I want that hacks hotter than a night of
the game of the air by that hair far
there are press linger extra how do you
even get hair like that so you walk
around this this piece of [ __ ] place and
you battle battle that [ __ ] for aria
the Opera Queen on now yeah wha-wha-what
one opera slinger without an opera hall
but it's an opera sing it anyway your
fans and fame are mine I know what am i
without you missed a spot
you selected those couple of teams back
seven arrow it's not over till the fat
lady sings and you are fat that's about
like I gotta get going right so you go
to these spotlights places I am starting
it quick Manville chorus here we go bras
now you will find
and that was pretty good I was pretty
good that's one down where's the next
spotlight where is the next my wife's a
spotlight moving away my adoring fans
well you must worship well they'd like
that I'd ever since unlike to badge that
spotlights I do anything I will not be
bettered by a talentless [ __ ] love
this game
eine kleine it oh you are
you're so charger displeased you are go
wasn't casual way you're ready by the
way your beauty call with frog crowd
hasty Oh to nail that nail net shed
another spotlight oh [ __ ]
I gotta make it to the spotlight you
actually think you have a chance what a
chair is stopping me from being awesome
how the [ __ ] do I get up there ah ah
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] she's gonna start
saying the [ __ ] gotta look at my hair
my hair is gorgeous go on that should
move to the scrub like first ones out in
two weeks doesn't matter did it really
Oh sing with me brother back i dead
cannibal you rose in my famiiy [ __ ]
me and Leslie I did
I like how I sing even though the lyrics
are right there I sing it wrong that's
pretty good I'd give myself up 4.5
average oh whoa whoa whoa I gotta make
this job Oh Dex
whoa whoa whoa whoa Murray and the Opera
even you are nothing before me shut up
what the [ __ ] this game is so fun
I got to go all the way around are you
[ __ ] my [ __ ] how do you even [ __ ]
in an [ __ ]
you got to pour it in with it like a
trapped or something I'm not I'm not
gonna make this one it's gonna start now
no we won't be able to see me sing I've
got to hurry to that light there that I
got it maybe if this [ __ ] text will
disappear
I could actually nail this jump but life
is a very good big but boys it is a bit
philippi i farm wearing the new face
stuff yes
what's up there we go I'm here I'm here
I'm in what job and now we were back in
this art and I invented respond not my
part should come back to it
and I feel like the game isn't working
is it just me or am i singing too good
one final song oh no oh no me to set the
stage Oh shet it's gonna be difficult
isn't it it's gonna be under but
probably I mean her butt is as big as
this in stock oh [ __ ] nice
dead dead oh I [ __ ] love this Bake
Ovens fed she's beginning without me
I've got to get down the [ __ ] I just
jumped down it's a turtle
I'm here
I didn't go well I tried Forte
I tried Sun rose did you really choose a
heart this is true I mean look at my
haircut look at that [ __ ] alright good
so that was opera Slager I am sorry
about your ears
all right breasts I love I love singing
song games it's fun I don't know why
anyway lack of it if you enjoyed its
this guy tacoma breath today and I'll
see you next everybody
hey guys where the [ __ ] ahead to a girl
wet that dripping whoa whoa I have to
warn you a little bit of a little bit of
a sauce